Africa definitely is the new China for
this realization of you know becoming
the next China it it's it's all based
around infrastructure so and I foresee
that really starting now you know I see
with the next 10 15 years a huge
explosion in infrastructure than I've
been development this is without
question along that you're going to see
an explosion of wealth in terms of the
luxury business which I'm very
particularly focused on in Africa we
know there's a market for luxury the
issue is the environments are not being
created which I'm very actually in in
trying to create the right platform for
that you've had a lot of firsts in your
career age 24 first to stage a show a
Paris Fashion Week first African tailor
to open a boutique on Savile Row
what first would you like to be known
for when it comes to the African luxury
market I think there's there's a real
opportunity to really define luxury so I
think luxury is is as a language has
changed over the period of time many
because there's more wealth as more
market soaping not there's development
so that footprint it's expanding so what
does lucky really mean and I'd like to
be able to review to crane that that new
formal language that sits around what
luxury is going to be in the future and
I feel that Africa will be a big key to
communicate that